that's not the plan
was the rock thing did it really get
dropped at it because obviously there
was the only fans thing right
um where he had the House of Blues house
which was successful for you yeah he had
a bunch of chicks coming out of the
Woodworks
um
you kind of revolutionized the only fans
thing for dudes yeah you know um
but for you
you're looking at that as I mean so he's
it's work so okay so it's coming in yeah
so like the first season to me was kind
of like oh you did not say he was doing
this this and that but now you're doing
this this and that so that's kind of
what sparks the whole initial like what
the [__] like but now I'm kind of like
okay I see what you're doing I see what
you're on
whatever but at first it was not like
that I was gonna say like and then
there's the there's the Christian thing
just get dropped like you're like wait
this is a thing like I've been like were
you telling her like don't worry about
her okay no no let me tell you let me
tell you the exact story so I did blue
Girls Club season one
in probably two days
season one but he stayed he not he gonna
leave that okay it's two days of season
one
um Kershaw was the youngest at the time
she was actually younger than I was
anticipating like I only wanted 21 and
up because everybody was drinking I
can't promote underage drinking
just slipped through the crack she was
like 20. so
and she was she was just as raunchy as
she is now she was just his
like irritable as she is now so none of
the girls liked her they all picked on
her they uh right you know so I kind of
maybe showed her a little bit more
attention and care of just because I'm
like you know you're the youngest like
thug it out see it through right
but she's at home watching like oh no
you like her you care about her what do
we win it's more it's more
so she pulls up the second day with her
friends to confront Christian Runs Out
hit something breaks her tooth
and so I'm not there at this time so I'm
not there to break anything up I come
back
um
or no I was there but I was upstairs
when she confronted Christian so I
didn't see anything or or dictate
anything I come downstairs for Sean's
ran out already
she's there my sister's there I'm like
bro what the [__] is y'all doing I'm
trying to run a a whole little thing
here and you guys are conflicting with
the business helicopter pull up it's a
whole big old deal like because
Christian ran out butt naked she
probably went to a neighborhood yeah
late at night it just seemed bad so
I come downstairs but Sean's gone she's
there my sister's out there they yeah
I'm like what the [__] is y'all doing
y'all [__] up my business so I start
tripping on them they leave now I'm
worried about Christian
following day day after she comes back
her tooth is like
it's not out but it's loose I'm like oh
my [__] God I know my big mama and my
sister did not just pull up and [__] her
not they didn't even touch her she ran
upset but not yeah you didn't see what
happened yeah it seems like it's my
fault you know because I'm hosting this
thing and then people that I personally
deal with
all right so now I'm feeling like a
disgusting human being because I'm like
damn this this 20 year old girl yeah you
don't think that you could have been
honest there was nothing to be it was
two days I just met the girl I didn't
even like I didn't even like her don't
say you sleeping somewhere and you're
not
I only had one camera man I was
unprepared I had eight girls One camera
man one camera man and about two
security guards right so after the first
day I'm like [__] this is I had to be a
security guard I had to stay the night
there and she wasn't okay with that
she's like oh you didn't tell you how to
stay tonight I mean is that not valid
though yes okay I get it you know I'm
playing counselor to the youngest person
who's more who needs more attention and
more attentive right so she's at home
watching it I'm recording everything
everything's live everything's
documentation
oh no that's the one you care about
that's that I'm like no she just hey
there's nothing like a female's
intuition though because what do you
mean like that's right she wasn't doing
art she wasn't she said fast forward a
couple of years listen you wanna know
why she wasn't right because if she
would have never done that
I don't think musician will even know
each other to this day because you felt
bad because yeah I only felt bad because
my baby mother put up this girl is not
from California she's the youngest girl
there my sister is with her you're
probably also worried like this girl
like it's just bad so now I'm not a damn
they pull it up and your tooth's missing
okay now I have to change your life I've
changed your life physically you'll
never you'll never grow that tooth back
that tooth will never come so that was
day two day two okay after day two well
first of all how many days in before you
sleep with Christian rock for the first
time I didn't sleep with rock till like
day twenty day twenty because I knew she
was kind of Jaden at daytime I know she
was kind of [__] with him freaked out
in her mind like she she wasn't she was
the way she is today she was like that
then she was just I think that there's
this rep that you know oh yeah no no no
just back then because we see because
listen you've seen the pictures of her
when she's like that's high school young
and then they're like look at her now
this is with her that's her face to put
you their pictures when she was 16 17. I
don't like that I Met Her Shine when she
was 20 right by then she had already
dropped out of college she had already
she messed up her knee from the tag show
so she wasn't athletically capable to
you know accomplish what she needed to
accomplished so that's why she was on my
show she was down and out she was like
looking for a way out
met her cool wasn't interested no
intention she comes up my with my sister
blood sister her and my blood sister
come chase her out of the house
hit her mouth miss her tooth now I'm
like what the [__]
do you regret that
I told her to this day it's your fault
that question still exists to me it's a
very narcissistic thing to say it is
very wow because that's exactly because
I know myself
I've done five seasons
I've never took any female Pastor let me
recant what I said it sounds like
because you you that could be your truth
you could be being genuine yeah right
but it's also like an easy thing to say
to be like no it's really not because
you know this is your fault I've done
five seasons and I've never have done
anything with any of the women after
after the season
during the season during the season I
have to see that I've never promoted
promoted these girls promoted them no
but none of them was able to go and get
a show or something like that so that's
cash but me and Christians off the show
so that's cats what I'm saying
me and Christian have only been in
business because I I didn't you don't
still feel bad because you paid I don't
still feel better you pay for the tooth
and it is what it is
do you think Blue's a narcissist I think
he has narcissist Tendencies right but I
don't think he is like a full-blown like
everything he does is with that intent
but there are some things he does where
I'm like I feel like okay now you're
trying to flip it on somebody else to
make yourself feel better I have a way
of acting out of emotion and
as a man once these actions are made we
don't get to just cover them up I mean
like I can't throw a temper tantrum in
here and throw a drink on you and slap
you and people be like well you did this
to her you did that to her if I did that
to you as a man you know they're gonna
hold me accountable right
right if I throw a drink on your sloppy
they're gonna say damn blue face
he didn't have to do that he didn't
deserve that but if she does it to you
they're gonna make up 101 excuses well I
think I think it it was a very
um abusive relationship because I think
I mean we saw when you guys were outside
of the was it the the spot on uh Lucky
Strike yeah you know and you were you
were like defending yourself yeah
because I'm like this listen Christian
is an athlete so and she's throwing
hands on you bro like I'm like what do
you want me to do you want me to get
[__] assaulted like and so for me I
think it's nice because I think that
obviously you have illegal [__] going on
and I feel like at all times
you were like a walking DV case waiting
to happen well because I feel like go
ahead go ahead I'm sorry I just feel
like that he's so
he's very calm so it's kind of like it's
kind of like you know he's really calm
so it's kind of like to spark that you
gotta be
like Off Your Rocker I'm like the Hulk
so it's kind of like you piss him off
you you sit down hit that switch it's
the other one then you're at home no no
it's like you you normally you push
people away like no don't do it I don't
want to turn into this on you I don't
want to do this I don't do this you keep
okay once the Hulk is awake [__] you
can't once the kill switch is flipped
man I feel you you can't tap rub my back
bro I'm gonna just like do some Hoka
Mania [__] and then once I do that
different Hulk there's Hulk Hogan I just
yeah no I'm bad right right I think that
you trigger I think everybody triggers a
different person than somebody so it's
kind of like
I let him be the star I don't really
kind of like I don't I'm not craving to
be the star I want him to be the star